il ya des gens qui veulent aller en
australie ici ouais
non ceux qui veulent y aller là vous
avez déjà regardé un documentaire sur
les animaux dangereux
ils sont tous là bas tout veut baiser
dans ce pays il ya des petites méduses
des requins des serpents je pense tu
peux te faire étrangler par le vent
je croyais à des arbres il poignarde des
gens ils violent les chèvres dans des
églises jamais je fous les pieds là-bas
vous souvenez il ya une époque à l'école
on nous parlait de la pangée c'est le
moment où sur la planète tous les
continents il faisait un seul gros
continent vous souvenez de ça moi je
pense ils se sont séparés à cause de
l'australie des amis
et un moment donné on la regarde et on
lui a dit écoute on va chercher des
clopes on revient
mais profitons pour réfléchir un petit
peu c'est quand même le seul endroit de
la planète où il ya des animaux qui
maîtrise la boxe
est fou
et on me dit tout le temps du nom mais
il faut y aller parce que les gens là
bas ils sont super ouvert d'esprit mais
tu m'étonnes qu'ils sont ouverts
d'esprit tu m'étonnes que tu vis au jour
le jour chaque journée est un miracle tu
te réveilles le matin tu la tiens dans
ma chaussure y avait un guépard
r
il faut y aller ils sont super ouvert
d'esprit mais raison de plus j'ai pas
envie d'aller dans un endroit où c'est
moi le plus grand fils de [ __ ] à des
kilomètres à la ronde ça m'intéresse pas
à paris
disons que je suis camoufler
fin mars
on n'est pas bon ici j'espère que vous
le savez
en termes de communication on est
éclatée on est nul on est nul hier à la
limite que ce soit entre nous à la
limite ça regarde la vie de chacun voilà
où ça m'énerve c'est quand ça touche au
business et les touristes il nous
apporte des millions des millions des
millions des millions vous avez vu
comment leur parle aux touristes
ils viennent nous voir et nous disent je
cherche une rude et tu cherches une rue
et on est dans une ville il y en a plein
des rues la lay line
il parle à moi dieu quoi tu prennes un
parapluie je me mette à guider les gens
des gages aux
échecs au café mac la bible il casse les
couilles le portoricain sais pas quoi
mes couilles la
passe après mais je pense pas il m'a
saoulé
[Applaudissements]